it is something that's kind of been lost
and it does make the elders happy and
excited that you're getting out there
and doing what they used to do
oh mama
[Music]
yeah this is the end
of the line right here
the fish are all spawned up now these
are a sockeye salmon some of them are
still spawning you can see eggs and
stuff in the water but the fish are kind
of like this all over the place up here
right now
I mean they're in the lake they're in
the Creeks I mean they're everywhere
you got to catch them as soon as they
get into the lake basically because once
they hit fresh water they stop feeding
and then they start basically dying
they start turning red and their meat
starts to turn white and they no longer
taste good at all and it's like mushy
it's like soft they're not good to eat
for the next couple weeks they'll be
fishing around just kind of dying and
floating up on the beach
until that the Bears have been come down
because all the all the grass is all
matted down and there's dead fish all
over the place this is kind of their
feeding ground
let's see what else I can see
oh man look at that the Bear's stashing
this fish right here it's Super Fresh
too and once the Bears get full they'll
kind of stop eating the whole salmon
they'll start eating like the good parts
like the belly and stuff I think I'm
gonna keep going a little more do a
little more exploring that's pretty cool
find
it's good just to get out explore steps
kind of always changing out here too you
know the topography the land and it's
good to see if the salmon are schooling
up in different places how many bears
are out about you know what all the
animals are up to this time of year
back here just kind of checking on where
the Bears are hanging out where the rat
about how many there are around
I mean there's there's a lot of bears
around here they will try to protect
their feeding ground that is something
you kind of have to worry about because
you're like right when they're eating
right now
I like kind of knowing what they're
doing where they're at firstly just so
you can stay away from them kind of a
thing because certain Years you'll have
more aggressive Bears some years you'll
have bears that break into stuff there's
that off chance that you run into that
bear that just wants to eat your face
off
I can hear the Bears moving around in
here but I can't see them I don't like
being as low to them I think I'm gonna
climb up this hill over here so I can
kind of see what's going on
I don't have to have a showdown with a
bear if I don't have to
oh the ground there
it's pretty big bear see over the left
now
growing up out here it's burnt into you
that you shouldn't really be afraid of
them
I mean you should respect them but they
do just want to leave you alone for the
most part
Three Bears just came out of the woods
by fighting over a fishing spot
they're pretty good size too they come
to check out the Salmon Creek I'm not
really worried about the Bears
especially because I have a gun they
don't really care about you especially
right now because they have like as much
food as they can eat
this time of year you can really see the
life cycle of everything you know
because the fish are coming up and
everyone everything kind of seems to
feed off the fish somewhat is this
thousands of fish out here the seals are
coming in to eat the salmon I mean the
Bears are here
be nice if I could get out catch some
Pike maybe shoot a seal them
you know a little variety
[Music]
thank you